Well, good evening church. So glad you guys are here
tonight. We get a special evening tonight.
It's a little bit out of the ordinary we get
to ordain some deacons and you're going to get to hear
a little bit here in just a bit. Just what these men have
gone through over the last 12 months
last year. This is a long rigorous process
of
Basically, just getting the torture them for a whole year. So we're
excited to get to hear from them and
see what God is doing in their lives what he's already
used them for and then what he's continuing to do through
their lives and the deacons are a big part of what we
do here at Henderson Hills and part of
God's plan for the local church. So you'll get to
hear about that this evening as well.
But before we get into that, we're
going to take a little bit of time to sing some songs together and worship.
And before we begin, let me go
ahead and pray for us.
Father we are so grateful that we get to be here
in this room tonight getting to to worship
you getting to see your plan
for the church and action here at
Henderson Hills. But God more
than just being focused on what we're doing here locally. We
want to give you glory and honor for who
you are and how you have stepped into creation and
we get to remember that during this Christmas season. I'm
focus on what you've
accomplished here on Earth when you
came some 2,000 years ago.
But what's the accomplish them, but you're still going to accomplish in the future
what you're doing in seouls tonight what you're
going to do in seouls tomorrow and 100 years from
now and into eternity and saving us and
redeeming us from the sin that
we were trapped in God. We
love you. We thank you for your faithfulness and your
goodness to us.
That's in your son's name. We pray. Amen. Well you go ahead and
stand with us as we get racing tonight.
Great Is Thy Faithfulness?
Oh God, my
father there is
no shadow of turning
with me.
without changes I
Passions
Great Is Thy Faithfulness
great is
I faithfulness morning by
morning new mercies.
I see all I
have needed.
Great Is Thy Faithfulness Lord
unto me
I could not love you
so blind and
unfeeling covered it
for me. This is still not
to me then with
that desire.
I found myself.
Great.
Is I faithfulness?
Greatest I faithfulness.
Only by morning new
mercies. I see
all I have
a name.
Pardon force in
a peace out into
it. I don't
depressants to
cheer and to God
strength for today and bright
faithfulness greatest I
faithfulness morning by
morning new mercies.
I see.
All I have a needed
life.
are done to
me
just see
glory to the newborn
king. Peace on Earth
and mercy miles wreck
against
rise. Join
that rhyme all the
skies with jelly
close broke clay Christ is
born in death. Just glory
to the newborn
king.
you
All right, seven adult
Christie Everlasting
Lord lead inside
me hold him come off
Spring of the Virginians
veiled in
flush God. It's easy.
suit
Jesus are and then
you will hardly arrows
Angels Sing glory to
the newborn Keys heal
the
sun of righteousness with
you
and Miles
Glory by
more than men
born to
you.
sing glory to
the newborn king
seen that again Born to
Raise the sons over.
Born to give them
second birth.
Mark the heroes. They
just see
glory to the newborn
king
Father we do praise you tonight. We bring you glory.
Tonight although we get to celebrate what
you're doing in the lives of these these men
and what you've done in there and their families and their lives
tonight and see what you're continued to do in
them. We want to give you glory and recognize that
none of this exists without your
son without Jesus and it
is all for him and all to him that we
gather tonight.
So more than anything we pray that you are glorified
this evening and his name is made great.
amen
Good evening.
Glad that you're all are here. It's my pleasure and
privilege to.
share a few words this evening and in honor of
our
Brothers that are coming to be ordained tonight Beau Brumley,
I'm Brad kesanki and Steve Stoltz. So
we're thankful that you could be here and my job
I guess is to talk a little bit about the qualifications
for the Deacon's and the process that
we follow and I want to thank Chris and Randy both deacons for
leading this in worship this evening.
So I'm also supposed to talk about what a deacon does and
before I start I was thinking about when
I first heard about Deacons.
I remember that in house where I grew up.
In Oklahoma City, we had a
piece of furniture.
In the front room.
And my mom called that the deacons bench.
so I asked her we're one time when I was a
Young lad why is it called the
deacons bench and she told me that it was the type of
beans that deacons of the church would sit on normally at
the back of the church.
So they could keep an eye on the congregation.
And make sure they were not misbehaving or sleeping.
And during the church service and and I
didn't start really going regularly to church until I was in the
seventh grade and started going to church at the
Baptist Temple down in Oklahoma City 30th and
Villa.
and so I started going to that church from the youth group there and
and I asked who were the men that were out in the
parking lot.
Walking around and some of them were smoking.
And I was told that those were the deacons of the church.
And they were on vigilante Patrol to make
sure the parking lot was safe.
So at that point in time I remembered now, maybe
that's a pretty good job. I might want to have some time walking around
in the parking lot not smoking but making
sure everything was safe.
So that's really my first recollection of deacons and
later on. I served as a deacon at
the Baptist Temple Church and First Baptist Edmund and
also here at Henderson Hills.
And I was trying to guess.
All total. I think I served as a deacon for over 35 years
before becoming an elder.
here at in August of 2021
I also remember I was in Charleston South Carolina
a long time ago on a trip and
I went to a church service in a Baptist Church in downtown
Charleston.
And for those of you been there's a lot of history there. And
so I think the church was founded in the
1700s.
And they were saying these stools at the back of
the sanctuary.
And in colonial times as I understand it the deacons would
sit on these stools.
And there were these long poles.
And they could use these poles to poke someone if
they fell asleep during the sermon.
So we don't do that today. We don't have any.
Stools or poles or benches at the back and we
don't poke you if you fall asleep because no
one would ever fall asleep during the message but deacons
are really not.
The the pokers or
the hitters. They are the the servant
Ministers of the church.
And so we're thankful for that and we're thankful tonight to to
honor these men into designate and
and set them apart for their calling.
so
Acts chapter 6
beginning in verse 1 now in these days when the
disciples were increasing in number a complaint by the hellenists arose
against the Hebrews because their widows
were being neglected in the daily distribution.
And the twelve some and the full number the disciples and said
it is not right that we should give out preaching the word of God to serve
tables.
Therefore Brothers pick out from among you seven
men of good repute.
Follow the spirit and of wisdom whom we will
point to this Duty.
But we will devote ourselves to prayer.
and to the ministry of the word
And what they said please the whole Gathering and they
chose Stephen A Man full of faith and the Holy Spirit Philip kuris
and the canore and time
and parminus and Nicholas prostate of
Antioch.
There's these they set before the apostles.
And they prayed and laid their hands on them.
And the word of God continued to increase and the
number of the disciples multiplied greatly in Jerusalem and a
great many of the priests became obedient.
to the faith
There are two offices of the church. I mentioned
in the Bible the first of these is that of overseer or
Elder. The second is the decent Deacon or
servant.
God calls the individual to either office and the
individuals recognized with great honor and this in
the church.
And is acceptance of the calling deacons are recognized
by their peers as humble servants and Ministers of
Mercy long before they're invited into the office of
deacon.
This demonstrates a commitment to the hard work of helping God's
people over time.
And I know each of the three men tonight and they've
been deaconing for a long time and we're
thankful for that and for their service.
It is Henderson Hills believed that both elders
and deacons are biblical designated as officers of the local
church.
Our ordination does not extend to other churches when an elder
Deacon moves to that church nor does an elder or Deacon from another church
who comes to our church automatically become an elder
or deacon.
In all cases Henderson Hills obeys the
biblical principle of absolutely affirming one's qualifications.
for the office
and let them also be tested first and then
let them serve as deacons if they prove themselves blameless.
The scripture I read act six and
then the Philippians 1:1 says Paul and
Timothy Servants of Christ. Jesus to all the
saints in Christ Jesus who are at Philippi with the
overseers and deacons. So that's the first New Testament
reference to the yacht in it.
In first 10:3-13. It talks
about I mentions the deacons rewards
for those who have served. Well as deacons attained
for themselves a high standing and great confidence
in the faith. That is in Christ Jesus.
Hebrews 13:17 says obey your
leaders and submit to them.
For they keep watching over your souls.
As those who will have to give an account.
Let them do this with joy and not with groaning for that would
be of no advantage to you.
A deacon is a biblically qualified servant officer
who is called by God and led by
elders.
Though deacons are subordinate Elders there to be
elevated even exalted within the church body Elders must
be careful to lead to deacons with Excellence communicating clearly
and frequently to avoid misunderstandings and
clarifying goals and responsibilities deacons should
be free to do the hard work of directing directly touching
people's lives elders and deacons must work together and
lead by example continually fostering
an atmosphere of love with trust and respect for each
other.
Deacons are the servant Ministers of the church as I said and they
have the honor of modeling for the local church and the Lost World.
God's compassion and kindness and mercy and love
as a church compassionately cares for people's needs the world sees a
visible display of Christ's love in each of these men.
Which will draw people to the savior?
Deacons are to be an example of commitment and unity and
Harmony in their service.
The deacons are to effectively and carefully administer the church's charitable
activities their agents of mercy and Distributors
of relief. They help the poor the jobless the
sick the widowed the elderly the homeless the shut-in and
the disabled.
They Comfort protect and encourage people and help
to meet their needs.
qualifications of a deacon
in first Timothy chapter 3 beginning in verse 8 deacons
likewise must be men of dignity not
double tongue or addicted to much wine or
found a sorted gang.
But holding to the mystery of the Faith with a clear conscience.
These men must also first be tested then let
them serve as deacons if they are Beyond.
reproach
deacons must be husbands of only one wife and good
managers with their children and their own household for those
who have served. Well as deacons obtained for themselves a high
standing and great confidence in the faith.
That is in Christ Jesus.
I've talked a little bit about the qualifications man
of dignity not double tongue.
Not addicted to much wine free from the love of many not
fond of sort of gain.
Holding to the mystery of the Faith with clear conscience. Let these
also first be tested.
you know, honestly I said earlier that
I had privilege of
serving as a deacon in other churches.
And the testing process that I
underwented at the other churches in
which I served in is quite different from the one that we've had at
Henderson Hills for many years.
For we spend nearly a year with each
of these men.
Not only do we
pray with them and discuss with them and hear
their testimony.
But we sit down and we go over some
material that talks about what it means to be a
deacon.
and
then they get to have a mentor a
deacon who's who goes with them through the process?
we also then give them 40 questions
theological questions that we give them
most of the summer to
to go through and to write answers and then they
turn those in and then we talk to them about their answers and tell
them that they were wrong and try again and but now
we don't do that, but we do encourage them and visit
with them and so the process
That I went through at Henderson Hills and the process that these
men tonight went through is extensive.
And we believe they've been tested well.
And we are as a deacon coordination team.
That's we don't really have Deacon officers,
but we have a coordination team that functions as
officers and they serve as the
leadership team of the deacon body.
The DC team DCT as we
call it is responsible for the overall direction and
coordination of all Deacon Ministries and is the
primary point of contact between the Deacon body.
And right now I have about 83 Deacons.
The Elder Council and the Pastoral staff
one of our Elder serves as a deacon facilitator
and that's TR Lewis. He couldn't be here tonight. Then there
are other Elders that serve I serve on the DCT and
Mark Wood before he went on sabbatical was
also an elder member of the DCT we have
Trevor Nall
and Rob Garrett and Chris Cross who have
served on the DCT this year and Rob
were kicking off and no
you're rotating off and we'll in
2023 Phillip. Slope will
be joining us on the DC team. We're glad to have you Phillip. So
thank you for winning one to serve and thank you rob saying all seriousness.
You made a great deal of difference in our DC team the past
couple of years that you served and we appreciate you.
So we
the Deacon facilitator and the Deacon team we get together.
We we met first with our Deacon candidates.
We asked them if they might be interested. We are we first
of all during the first part of the year. We let our
church body know that we'll be
accepting nominations or persons that want
to submit somebody's name. And then we review those names
review those with the church staff and with the elders. We also
then contact the persons
and ask them if they might be interested. The whole process is
meant to be and very confidential because of
any one point in time. It may be that a person
might want to step out of the process. So as I mentioned we do
a schedule we do a study and have classes
and additional interviews. We have the opportunity
to meet with their spouse and make sure
that everyone kind of knows what we're talking about here and
we talked about the 40 questions and then
we do a final interview and then if everyone is still on
the same page and wants to proceed they recommended the elders
and then ultimately the church
Will vote on them and and then
we were here tonight about and that's
the process that we follow.
so
every time the Deacon body meets we remind ourselves of
our calling and our responsibilities.
We continue to read these scriptures over and
over and over again, and we
continue to remind ourselves how important
our job is some principles
that we have identified is that as deacons. We
have been called qualified and equipped by God for the work of
his church.
We are accountable to God to the elders to each other
into the congregation for our words and our actions as Church
officers. We expected to be role models of Christian character
and living.
Man of dignity and integrity truthful trustworthy
sober-minded faithful and marriage
and leading our family. We assist the elders with
their pastoral care of the congregants enabling the elders to focus on
their god-given responsibilities of leading feeding and protecting
the church.
As deacons we serve with the attitude of Christ humbly lovingly
sacrificially and joyfully and
those who serve well gain a good standing for the
cells and a great confidence in the faith.
Me a little bit of word about that humbly.
We have deacons have all been provided
with a name tag that has their name in
the word deaconundrea.
And we have always encouraged the deacons to wear those and it's
like pulling teeth to get a deacon
to where a name tag because why because they
don't want to stand out. They they want
to work they want to do what God has called
them to do, but they're not they don't do it for recognition.
and so we keep working on that and
I don't wear my name didn't wear my name tag either but
What is a deacon do well we look after the
widows and widowers of our church, which is one of the greatest
blessings that each one of us have.
To be assigned a widow or widow or one or
two to check on them on a regular basis to see what we can do
to to walk aside walk side by
side with them and which is a very difficult time often.
Many of our widows and widowers do not have family nearby or
may not have family and so the importance of
looking after them and seeing how that we
could assist them Deacon's wise work hand in hand
and help us in those very important tasks. And
we also have the opportunity to in many
occasions to go to hospitals and visit with folks and check
on folks and see how they were doing encouraged them
to pray with them and then there's Ministries to
the homebound Ministries to nursing homes. There's Ministries
to Children of single parents and those who
do not have parents we a big
responsibility. We have a team of deacons who look after our
benevolence Ministry and people who come to
our church and need help financially. And so
we that's a deacon responsibility dealing with financial counseling
or help some Ministry. A lot of folks need some help with things around
their house. And so that happens through our Deacon team
Lord's supper and baptism and greeters.
Those things are also coordinated with the
leadership of our Deacon body.
so Deacons
are to spot and
meet tangible needs when they see them.
They're to protect and promote Church Unity.
There to serve and support the elders.
But I will say that.
Deaconing is not for the faint of heart.
It is a high calling.
It is a privilege.
It is an honor to serve those.
I can think back to the widows. I
have been blessed to serve.
And I can tell you that they bless me more than I ever blessed
them.
And so
Steve Brad and Beau
beginning does not for the faint of heart, but I know you're up to
it and I look forward to serving with you.
So they're deacons and Elders in the audience that will look
forward to serving with you.
So God bless you men and your families.
And let me pray quickly heavenly father. Thank you for our time
tonight.
And as we learn more about these men now I pray that
you will guide them that you will strengthen them that you
will continue to give them wisdom.
And thank you for their service to our church.
Thank you for their families who support them and stand it's
stand right by their side.
Before we pray these things in your name and for your sake. Amen.
All right, if you three men will come join me up here on
stage.
They look very reluctant.
Said anywhere you want.
You know when Steve was talking about?
the
Elder sin in the back watch him. Make sure people don't sleep. I thought
man. That sounds like a pretty good job.
and then I realized I'm usually the one sleeping during the service
so I probably wouldn't do very well at that but
Church, this is a this really is a fun night for us
as the DCT and for these men and their families as as we
finish up this process, you know,
we've got to spend the better part of the last year. Just getting
to know these man walk through the process with them and it really
has been a great joy to do that. But we
just we wanted to you to get to hear a little bit from them
tonight about their from about their hearts and and
their families and what they do and
and so Brown let's start with you and
Tell introduce yourself introduce your
family tell us about your family where you're from.
And what you do for a living?
All right. Well, I'm Brad cosenke.
Blessed have been married to Tamara.
For 25 years as of this year.
And we've got four kids. We're all here with us tonight. It's
okay. It is 19 student at Oklahoma State
Grant is 17 student at
Edmond Memorial.
Ben is 14 Grace is 11. They both
go school at Oakdale.
And we've been here at Henderson Hill since 2006.
When we move to Edmond, I
was born and raised in Lone Wolf, Oklahoma.
Maybe a few of you have heard of it.
My sisters are here tonight as well with their family and my mother-in-law father-in-law.
My sister's go to church here as well.
So that makes three of us and also know one other.
Lone Wolf graduate that goes to school Henderson Hill,
so I think we're representing pretty well for a town of 400 people.
So
Let's see. He said what I do for a living, I work in
the John Deere business manage the parts and service
operations for pancake equipment. Where a John
Deere.
Farm and lawn and garden equipment in Oklahoma and Arkansas. So
that's what I've done. I've been in the John Deere business ever since
I got out of college.
At Oklahoma State. Thank you.
Anybody that's not Brad's family ever heard of loan.
Lone Wolf. Wow, that's a
lot. Okay.
Bo
hi, my name is Bo Bromley.
My wife is Kristen. We got
married in 2013. So that's
Nine years ago.
We grew up in Tulsa.
And we got married just out
of college. So we graduate I graduated from OSU in 2013 moved
to Edmond and got married
just two months later and came to Henderson
and those following months. I think one of the biggest things that Drew us
here is at the time it felt like it was a big church,
but it broke down into Community
really well and I think that Community like sucked Us
in and we felt like we were plugged in immediately. We
we started getting active in different Ministries.
So I think that was one of the things that really
Drew us here and that was that was 2013. Yeah. So
right at the same nine years
And we have three kids. We have
Porter who's six?
He just started kindergarten this year and then we have Kaya who's
three and a half?
And Rhett who's 18 months one and
a half.
What else what are you I'm an
engineer in oil and gas. So it's it's been a
wild ride. I've been a Devon since since the
graduated again. So it's we've seen some UPS. We've seen a lot
of dance. We're back up. That's great. Yeah,
and my wife has had the opportunity to teach
Porter and Kaya in CLC, and
I can tell you
She loves them. I think that's because of their mother, but she
does love them. So.
Good evening. My name is Steve Stoltz.
I'm from Denison, Texas. Originally moved to
Oklahoma City when I was nine pretty much
grew up here. So kind of call this home now married to
Amanda for 38 years and we
have two adult children Katie stultz lives in
Oklahoma City and Jason and his wife
Mallory and our two grandchildren that live here in Edmond.
We
moved back here from Texas with my
job in we lived
in Oklahoma City and moved away gone for seven years and moved
back here and landed in Edmond when we returned
from Texas been here since
so I was a I've retired
at the end of 2020. It was a management employee
with Transportation Company
ups for 40 years and number
of different things mostly operations
type management and then in the engineering
department for about 10 years.
so
Enjoyed been here at Henderson House. Roughly. I
don't know look at my wife 20 years
18.
Oh, well something like that have enjoyed
serving here. And a number of capacities have
always been generally active
in church and many different ways. So happy to
be here. I appreciate that and and math is
not a qualification to be a deacon. So we
have some issues up here with that. But Steve, let's
start with you since you already have the microphone and you
just give us kind of just a short version of
your testimony. And and when
I say sure just keep it less than an hour and and then
maybe talk about where you're currently serving.
Sure.
Different than well. I say different way, but I grew
up in a Christian home. My parents
were both Christians. And so
we were in church from
Early age birth, you know and I was
at least my and my two sisters so grew
up in church.
unlike many individuals who
have different testimonies in that regard.
Came to know the Lord at
the age of nine and so and pretty
much been in in the church ever since love the
church.
Haven't been straight away and brought
and come back and those type things there's many testimonies of
individuals who?
Go through some hard times and difficult times and become Believers
and in the Lord's miraculously changes
their lives and that's not
my story. My story is I've been in
church most of my life, but the one thing that I remember
being in Nicaragua and hearing a
similar testimony of a man that was on the trip with us
and
Difficult times he'd gone through and different things and came to the
Lord in his life turned around. It's marriage strengthened and so on and so
forth and those are incredible testimonies, but at the
same time, I think the Lord for those
who
Haven't been through those difficult times but yet
still have that Saving Grace because we
all need forgiveness of sins and and I'm
a sinner and and have that forgiveness. And
so therefore a child of the king and grateful for
that those other thing currently serving
have served
in the cafe for a number of years not currently there
but most recently joined back
with as the choir has kind of
because become a part of some Services
again, enjoy leading in Worship in
whatever way whatever capacity that I
have the opportunity to do and I love to sing. I
love music. I Loved lyrics
and thankful for a church who emphasizes the
words of music and not just Rhythm and eat
and and sound and different things so currently loving
the opportunity to lead in
Worship in those opportunities in those ways.
Thank you bow.
Um, yeah, so like like Steve I was born and raised to
a Christian family. My parents are here. I'm appreciative. They
I remember going to church forever my
whole life it I remember being a second home
to me it
Every opportunity we had I felt like we were there
through through being at
church all the time. I remember constantly hearing the gospel through Sunday
school and and constantly
through sitting in big church. Just just
hearing the gospel over and over and over and it first
hit me hard whenever I was eight years old.
And that's when I that's when it came to Faith and then
as I've as I've matured
like that process of just hearing the gospel over and over
and how you continue to hit me and hit me and change my life has continued
to happen and I feel like there have
been times whenever I've pursued God hard and
he is he has changed me in this times and there have
been times whenever I feel like I haven't pursued God is
hard and I still look back on those times and God is still changing me
then and has continued to
sanctify me throughout throughout life. But that repetition of
the Gospel is always come back constantly in
my life. So I felt that so that's just a
bit of my story.
As far as the Ministries that I've been
in we Chris and I have been plugged in and several
since we've been members here. We started
off in the college Ministry.
And we were there for I don't know a couple years this times
man. They get blurry real quick. Don't they?
The college Ministry for a couple years. We spent some time in Hillside kids with
young ones like one or two year olds currently our
serving the high school Ministry.
This is our fourth year there we started with the
current senior class for freshmen
and we've kind of got to step up with them each year. So it's
it's really been a privilege for us to to
start off investing in kids and watching
them mature being able to invest in them.
I feel like it takes several months just to to Break Down The
Walls and get to know them and then ever since
that point we've just like Stuck Like Glue and and now
as they've gone on we've continued to be able to pour into
the lives. I try to share our life as an
example to them end up learning a whole lot from them
in the process and I feel like
at the end of it here. We we end up with just having a
bunch of really close family friends and getting to know them well
and their families. Well, it's it's really been
a blessing to us.
All right. Well, I as well, I was born into Christian
Home blessed to have parents
that were.
Strong believers they have both passed away
or both with the Lord now, but we're no
doubt.
credible influence on my life
and in addition to that grew up in a really small
church, but it was a really sound Bible teaching
church was blessed to have grown up
in that kind of environment where
even in that small church or a lot of people p***
truth in my life and
when I was 13, it became clear to me that
I was a sinner and I
needed forgiveness and gave my
life to Christ and trusted him as my savior was baptized
in that church and
Like I said, I feel like my testimony. My life
is kind of a testimony of God. Just continuing
to pursue me.
and bringing people into my life that have
helped me grow closer in my relationship with the
Lord certainly bringing.
A Godly young woman into my life that became my wife.
She's been a huge influence on me.
As well as many other people.
and we've been blessed in our marriage with our
family and a lot of ways and we've
had some hard times too, but
Through the Lord's sanctifying process
those hard times. I think I've drawn me into a closer relationship
and just deepen my faith. And and that's
also something I think I took from my parents to
just trust in.
The sovereignty of God and I've kind of seen that play out
in my life and that's come back to me as I've gotten older those lessons
that I learned from them.
And so
thankful for that for sure. And as far as
where I'm serving for the last several years have been
serving here at Henderson Hills and Middle School Ministry.
I think this is my sixth year teaching Middle School boys
some leading co-leading in 8th
grade boys group right now with Adrian savedra
and
You know, I didn't think that that's something that I
would be called to.
But man, it's been a huge blessing to me.
I Love Leading Middle School boys
It's just such a amazing age
and you see the development from you know,
sixth grade seventh grade eighth grade. There's a
lot of physical development for sure, but just
a tremendous amount of Spiritual Development that's
happening during those three years and
Kind of come into the understanding of what it means to not just
know about Jesus but to know Jesus never relationship with Jesus and
being able to play some kind of a small part in
that has been a blessing to me. It's strengthened my faith and
being blessed to be
able to lead them. So yeah, that's kind of where I've been
serving and currently serving.
Praise God. Yeah, I
I think many of us in here and me especially I've
seen you all the way you serve and it's
certainly a blessing to to me and
into the church body. So we
thank you all for that.
Brad let me ask you.
What is your favorite book
of the Bible?
Love Romans, I would
probably I would probably go with Ephesians.
love Ephesians 2 1 through 10 and just
clear picture of just the Redemptive work
of
Jesus Christ Our Lives, so that's probably
that's probably floats to the top for me.
Yeah, excellent.
Alright bow, we have a different question for you.
How does the way that deacons
serve the church make an impact in people's
spiritual lives?
Yeah, I think I think that's it. That's a good question. I think a
lot of that is really like the main function of of
deacons and what Steve talked about
tonight it to me. It starts a lot
with the work of the Elders of the church shepherding the church well, and
then the the Deacon come alongside and
assist them in carrying that out and serving the church that it
looks a lot of different ways. It looks like caring for the
widows and and the widowers and
it looks like a lot of behind the scenes things
and a lot of ways. It's the the hands
and the feet behind protecting the church serving the
church loving the church and I kind
of like to look at it as
Um following Christ's command. It's viewing
the church as the bride of Christ and and caring for
it. Well, so it really takes a lot of
a lot of faces, but it's carrying out the Ministries set to
care and protect the church.
It's great.
And Steve, where do you see the the
unique passions in
giftings that God has given
you where do you see those adding elements to
our Church's Ministry?
to our white Minister our Church's Ministry
much of kind of what boo had
mentioned. I've always been one who kind
of works behind the scenes
don't like, you know, most you're going to see out of me is leading in
worship to acquire but have always been willing to
serve behind the scenes and helping ways
that are tangible whether it's
families or
single people in our church had
just supporting the church body in that way and and
Meeting the needs of those people as best
we can I know I've served alongside didn't even
know.
years ago that there were different
groups of Deacon helps team and different things
and I just get involved with some men and go with them
and help, you know, when we had ice storms and cut tons
of trees off of houses and out of yards
and carried them away and things of that nature and just serving ladies come
to find out widows and different people is who
we were serving and I was serving right alongside her being drawn in
by some of you deacons and knew that
I had some available time and and willing to do that and
they would ask me and I just joined them in that effort and
not knowing really what I was getting involved with but
you know just serving the church
body in that way and tangible ways is
a blessing in my life and then
knowing the leadership
that we have and and praying
for our elders our staff our
pastors is
always on my heart they have
A greater. I feel like greater responsibility than even
the deacons do and and lifting them
up and and asking the Lord guidance and
protection upon their families their lives is something
that we need within the church and happy to
bring those men before the Lord
and pray for them often. So that's great. I
appreciate that. And this is
for all three of you Steve will start with you. What's what's as you've
gone through this process that for the last year, you know,
so what's what's one thing
that you've enjoyed or maybe that you've learned from this
this Deacon process.
One thing I've learned is when they tell you that there's 40 questions.
They don't tell you that there's ABC and
D associated with them. So it is a being 120 or
however many there are so it's not
40, but that process in and
of itself was was probably the longest process
at least for me. I'm not
a student in Reading quickly
and well and remembering well and a lot
of times and so just digging through commentaries and
and the word of God and and really fleshing
out what your beliefs are and why
those why you have those beliefs that process
I'll still
go back and reflect on those questions, but that
process was probably the most meaningful and
then meeting with some of
the deacon team and in kind
of discuss it having a discussion of those questions and and
them asking clarification on some
things and getting an opportunity to talk about that and
and share your heart and and listen to
what they may have say about the same question and
getting it maybe a different perspective in that
regard so that that was probably like I
said the lengthiest process and
and the one that
really is most meaningful to
me and having a greater understanding
of the deacon process and just grounding
ground getting being more
grounded in in what you believe and why you believe it.
Now that's that's great and and church, you know,
the the questions that that these men answered and
that we use deacons and even Elders have
to answer in some form probably more extensive, but
they really are deep questions and
and make us think but it really is a blessing to
do it and enjoy to even though
it can be challenging. I I still have mine and
in can go back and look at them. So that's that's a beautiful
thing.
Um, yeah, I mean, I agree that's I've told a lot of people
I think that process of answering those questions. I
think it's good for everyone honestly for myself.
I I didn't
have any Monumental shifts changes in my beliefs
because of those but I I was able to like have
the biblical basis behind that.
So instead of instead of thinking something because it
was traditional it was tradition and I thought
that my whole life I can now have have this
basis which is ground in scripture for
for that that backing but if
I had to answer my own answer instead of piggyback
and Steve I would say I I realized going
into this process really early on that. I wasn't entirely
sure what the deacons do. So I I was
able to I I really enjoyed the stock
book and learning more about
that learning the caveats learning what examples we
have with.
In the New Testament there.
I think that was something that I definitely wanted
to learn pretty early on in the process and I felt like I was able to do that.
Well, I'm going to Echo what both of these guys said I'm gonna piggyback on your
piggyback and say that.
Yeah, I thought that that process was really good and I've told
multiple people as well. I think it would be
good process for anybody to go through whether you're
going through a deacon candidate
process or not. I think.
Going through that process of considering praying
through.
Understanding the Biblical basis for why you
believe what you believe and then the process of actually putting that down
and riding.
I think was really good and just cementing my
faith and actually building my faith. It's amazing how the Lord can work
through things that you you know already believe in just
the process of kind of
reiterating those things can actually build your faith even further,
but
yeah, I enjoyed that and I think it was it was
good and just
like I say even helped develop my faith even
further.
Now, that's great. And and like I said at the
beginning guys, it's been a great joy and privileged to
get to walk through this this process with you. And I think
every time I've gotten to go through it I learned more about
what a deacon does and is supposed to
do and is supposed to be and it's it's
it's really an honor to get to serve
the body. So what we're
gonna do now is we're gonna
have each one of you one by one. We'll call your name.
You'll walk down here John will present
you with the certificate. You'll take a picture as these
men come down if families are here if you'll
make your way up to join them and then
John will say a few things and church.
It's okay to cheer.
when when we when I call their name, right this is and
and I say that but it's funny but
Like this is God's faithfulness right here to provide
us and call men to be Deacons.
This is this isn't a popularity contest. I
mean, I like all these men but they're not sitting up here because I like them or because
the DCT likes them it's because it's God's calling their life.
And so let's let's praise God for that.
So we'll start here.
with
always want to call you Ben, but I'm not going to Brad kosanki.
Yeah, right.
And then if the cosanki family
could come join him and then next we have
Bo Bromley.
And then last but certainly not least is Steve stolz.
All right, so you families can come around first.
And let you all gather there and then as they're
coming up here then deacons and Elders who
are here as well. You can come on up and we're going to surround them
and pray over them.
And then if you just want to after they
make their way up here as well, then you can come pray
over them as well. We're gonna pray and then
we're gonna sing one more song and we do have a reception
out there afterwards for you. So the reason
we do it this way as they're coming up is you're coming up
to pray over them is because of what Steve said earlier Acts
chapter 6 talks this way that that these were
brought before the apostles and really the whole church and they
laid hands on them and prayed and
that was this sort of ordination Ceremony this
sort of commissioning you might say for
their role as deacons. So
that's what we're doing here tonight and commissioning them
towards the ends that you've heard over
and over again tonight, but then verse 7, don't
forget and the word of God continue to multiply and many
more disciples kept coming to Christ as
a result.
Of the calling of the deacons because it
really propelled the ministry of the church in the ways you've heard
tonight and many others and so that's what we're doing tonight is just praying
and trusting God's going to use this even for more Ministry in
his kingdom. So let's pray now in this ordination moment
ordaining them officially as
deacons of Henderson Hills God. Thank you so much
for this celebration tonight that it is.
That these three men have been deaconing been
serving in varieties of ways already
and this is just an official recognition of their
their first their character that they
were men of good repute. Good reputation.
That we've watched them for years have seen
and heard affirmation after
affirmation of their heart their character.
their integrity
both in the church outside the church. We're thankful for that
God that this is
this is done tonight with full confidence.
That they are yours that they are exemplary in their
character first, but then also got thank you for their hearts that
have led them to serve as as the
leading servants now of the church is deacons that
they have the opportunity to care and love
and and serve even
from way behind the scenes. No one will
ever know most of what they do.
But you're always watching God. You're always seeing.
Thank you for their hearts in that. I thank you also for their
wives their children their families.
Who sacrifice a lot as well?
as they serve alongside these men as
they
allow these men to go serve and spend time outside of
their homes without them being there.
It's a sacrifice and so we're thankful for those
wives and children and they're willingness
to be a part of this process and serving alongside their
their husbands their father.
Thank you. God for what you've done tonight to
just reaffirm to these men. I pray they would feel loved and valued
and encouraged and challenged and cherished first
by you. But then also by us as Elders by
us as a church.
That we are setting them apart now by this
act of laying on of hands this ordination moment.
But God we pray that it would not just be an affirmation
of them and their value to you to the kingdom to the
church.
But it would be something that propels the mission forward.
That many more would come to see you Jesus through
these men their service to you their their ability
to free up us as Elders to
to teach the word to Shepherd the flock that we can do
this better because of them.
That our churches cared for better because of them that
more people are loved well and cared for
well because of them.
So God may all of our deacons feel that.
May our church know that and how important this
role is.
Thank you. God that you've set it up this way. You've
ordained it to be this way. And now we get to be a
part of it. So I pray they would feel your love and your
your blessing as they go forward protect them
Lord. This is this walking into the
teeth of the enemy his his desire is
to seek and kill and destroy and so we know that they're in the
crosshairs in some ways. And so we pray your protection over
them.
That our church would pray deeply for our elders for
our deacons staff that we would feel safe as
you set your angels around us you protect
us God.
Start with them and their families to even tonight. They feel
your peace as they serve you with all their hearts keeping
their eyes on you not on fame or recognition or
anything else. They know you watch and you see and
you reward.
But we want to do this for your glory god. Thank you for these
men. These families represented tonight. We're grateful bless
them in Jesus name. Amen. Amen.
He goes head back to your seats. We will have time of course afterwards and
the reception but we want to end as Jesus did
with his disciples very often would end with him and
they would go out singing and so we're gonna sing this to
close our time tonight again, we can be out in the lobby. Just
enjoying time together as we close tonight. So
if you stand with me if you're able and let's worship Jesus.
Let's see
this either should nothing of
our
Earth stand no lay you see
survive.
Unless the Lord
does raise the house.
to you post to
Mars gain tell me
What is your life a mess
that fan is she that
don't all know?
Christ Our King all glory
be to Christ his
Rule and
rain will see
all that got
shot
Oh glory be to
Christ and all the
glory be to Christ Our
King all glory be
to Christ his rules.
All day one more
time.
So glory be to Christ
his room.
Oh.
Glory be to cry.
Amen, and I get to say at this
time you guys are sent.